major major news yesterday Donald Trump
and his family are getting sued New York
yes they are suing Trump and the case is
being referred to the Internal Revenue
Service the IRS for criminal prosecution
this is this is really important that
the key detail here is this is totally
separate from the FBI search warrant
this is unrelated this is a totally
different thing as the legal problems
are stacking up up up higher and higher
to the moon for Donald Trump and his
family this relates to the fraudulent
representations of asset values exactly
as our friend Michael Cohen testified
about and will talk to us about when he
joins us later this month on the program
CNBC article New York sues Trump company
and family members over widespread fraud
claims seeking at least 250 million
dollars in penalties
New York attorney general Leticia James
sued Trump
org as well as Eric Don Jr and Ivanka
for allegedly widespread fraud As Trump
says involving false financial
statements related to the company Mr
Trump's statements of financial
condition from 2011 to 2021 were
fraudulent and misleading in both their
composition and presentation that's CNBC
patch.com
explains more about what is believed
that Donald Trump and his family did
claiming money that you do not have does
not amount to the art of the deal said
Leticia James in the civil suit
Wednesday
James says Trump repeatedly and grossly
inflated the value of properties in a
long-standing game of smoke and mirrors
so I'll explain the gist of this and I
think to some in our audience you
already know this but it's worth
explaining
what is the point of saying a property
you have is worth more or is worth less
than it really is and it has to do with
are you trying to get a loan using that
property as collateral or are you trying
to avoid property taxes on a particular
property let's say I have not a perfect
building in New York but a nice building
and it's worth 10 million dollars in
reality now in reality
Trump's defenses that property values
are subjective and of course that's true
but let's say that on average
independent appraisers say a building is
worth 10 million dollars if you need a
15 million dollar loan
the 10 million dollar building is not
going to suffice its collateral in
general you can get generally speaking
80 percent loan to value meaning for a
10 million dollar building you can only
get a loan of 8 million dollars against
it so in order to justify the 15 million
dollar loan Trump can say this this is a
great building this is a 20 million
dollar building and now that would
enable him if the bank believes it to
give him a 15 loan against it so that's
when you inflate the asset value on the
other hand
incomes the property tax collector the
real estate uh tax collector and says
you've got a 10 million dollar building
here
you owe us money for property taxes
based on 10 million and then Trump can
make a completely different case and say
now listen the toilets aren't so good
you got to flush them 10 to 15 times as
Trump often complains about and uh you
know Jared Kushner is evicting people
and all these different things it's not
worth 10 million it's only worth 5
million so tax me on the 5 million it's
a type of fraud
and it relates to keeping two sets of
books and it relates to a whole bunch of
other accounting and different types of
fraud so this is the Crux of it now
we've got a couple of videos here from
the attorney general Leticia James and
she has quite a bit to say about all of
this
Mr Trump also blatantly ignored legal
restrictions at Mar-A-Lago
Mar-A-Lago was valued on the false
premise that it sat on unrestricted
property and could be developed for
residential use
however
Mr Trump knew that Mar-A-Lago was
subject to a host of onerous
restrictions and limitations
Mr Trump himself signed Deeds sharply
restricting changes to the property and
donating his residential development
rights in an effort to get a tax
deduction and later to lower his
property
taxes on the property exactly the Deeds
also require Mr Trump to donate over 23
percent of mar-a-lago's value to the
historic trust for historic preservation
if he ever sold it
despite these significant restrictions
Mr Trump valued the property based on
the false premise that it was an
unrestricted residential 18-acre plot of
land that could be sold and used as a
private home
in fact the valuations represent that
these restrictions
don't even exist
the club generated annual revenues of
less than 25 million dollars
and should have been valued at more than
valued at about 75 million dollars
however Mar-A-Lago
was valued
as high as
739 million dollars bit of an
exaggeration that's for sure and Leticia
James they're outlining just more
examples of the type of thing that I'm
talking about now what is she seeking
well in addition to 250 million dollars
in Damages her goal is to prohibit any
of Trump's companies from doing business
in the state of New York
and lastly
to cancel any certificate filed under
and by virtue of the provisions of
section 130 of the general business law
for the corporate entities named as
defendants
and any other entity controlled by or
beneficially owned by Donald Trump which
participated in or benefited from the
ongoing Financial scheme
in other words
permanently prohibit any of these
companies
from doing business
in the state of New York now we don't
know whether any of these things are
going to happen we don't know whether a
single dollar is going to be collected
here in this lawsuit we don't know
whether Trump and his family will
actually be barred from doing business
in New York but what we do know is that
the legal problems are mounting and the
legal bills are exploding dramatically
here now Donald Trump is of course on a
tirade about this and we'll get to that
in a moment but understand that these
are mechanisms which
anyone in a sense could could try to
take advantage of if you have a house
that's worth three hundred thousand
dollars you could try to get a favorable
favorable appraisal if you want to get a
home equity line of credit uh and you
could also call the local tax assessor
and say the property is terrible it's
not worth that much to lower your
property taxes a little bit but we're
talking about thousands of dollars there
here we are talking about tens if not
hundreds of millions of dollars that
impact dramatically tax Collections and
Loan money that is put at risk by
Financial corporations this is very
serious so it should be taken seriously
we are going to follow where this goes
two points that have been made about why
it will be difficult for Leticia James
to Prevail in this lawsuit number one
there is a disclaimer that is included
in these valuation documents by the
Trump organization which says property
valuations are subjective now whether
that is enough to clear someone of fraud
liability is going to have to be
investigated but one claim is we say
this is subject to uh uh it is
subjective period
um and then number two proving that
Donald Trump really meant to deceive and
that he was even personally involved all
of these are obstacles certainly to
holding Trump accountable but the legal
problems mounting and Donald Trump
completely exploding about this one of
our sponsors today is BusyBox child I
know that there are many parents in our
audience this is for you busy box child
offers really great subscription boxes
for kids filled with sensory toys that
will help your toddler to Elementary age
child stay off screens and do some
really interesting stuff technology used
by kids is at an all-time high
especially after the pandemic playing
off of screens is really critical for
development for cognitive development
social emotional well-being for kids
it's an ideal opportunity for parents to
engage with kids as well Carolyn is the
founder of busy box child she's a mom
and a child clinical psychologist who
designs all the boxes that you receive
busy box child offers monthly sensory
kits with different themes for each
season or you can get a monthly sand bin
subscription for hours and hours of fun
check out their mini jars and mini kits
for playtime on the go BusyBox child is
a small business that supports the David
Pacman show support them go to
busyboxchild.com and use the code Pacman
for 10 off the link is down below